usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido recientemente diagnosticada
con cáncer de mama este vídeo le ayudará
a entender qué es el cáncer de mama y
cómo afecta a su cuerpo
y los senos son un par de órganos
ubicados directamente debajo de la piel
en el tórax en el exterior de la mamá
está el pezón el círculo de piel más
oscura que lo rodea se llama areola
en las mujeres los pechos están hechos
de tejido graso
glándulas productoras de leche y tubos
llamados conductos
hay una amplia red de vasos linfáticos y
ganglios linfáticos en la mama y
alrededor de ella el fluido de las mamas
se drena a través de los vasos
linfáticos hacia los ganglios linfáticos
si el fluido contiene sustancias nocivas
como bacterias o virus las células
inmunes dentro de los ganglios
linfáticos las atacarán y destruirán
[Música]
desde allí la mayor parte del fluido
pasa a los ganglios linfáticos que están
debajo del brazo y luego a otros
ganglios y vasos linfáticos que
desembocan en el torrente sanguíneo
la mayoría de los cánceres de mama se
inicia en los conductos de la mama pero
puede crecer en cualquier parte de la
mama
aquí se forman células cancerosas a
partir de las células que recubren los
conductos estas pueden crecer y
multiplicarse para formar un tumor
canceroso con el tiempo las células
cancerosas pueden propagarse a través de
los ganglios linfáticos
y los siguientes pueden ser signos o
síntomas de cáncer de mama tenga en
cuenta que estos signos y síntomas no
incluyen todos los casos durante un
examen mamario de rutina usted o su
médico pueden sentir una pequeña
protuberancia dura en su pecho o debajo
del brazo
además es posible que salga un poco de
líquido del pezón
o bien es posible que vea hoyuelos en la
piel de la mamá
su médico usará ciertos términos para
describir la evolución de su cáncer
llamada esta edificación la
estadificación del cáncer de mama es
compleja
las siguientes descripciones de esta
edificación son una visión general y no
incluyen todos los casos
la etapa 0 significa que se encuentran
células anormales pero que no se han
diseminado más allá de donde empezaron
hacia otros tejidos de la mama
la etapa 1 significa un tumor menor de
dos centímetros en el tejido de mama
la etapa 2a significa que la mamá puede
tener cáncer en los ganglios linfáticos
de la axila o bien puede ser un tumor de
dos centímetros o menos con cáncer en
los ganglios linfáticos de la axila la
etapa 2a también puede ser un tumor de
entre 2 y 5 centímetros sin diseminación
a los ganglios linfáticos
la etapa 2b significa que la mama puede
tener un tumor de entre 2 y 5
centímetros con cáncer en los ganglios
linfáticos de la axila o bien puede
tratarse de un tumor mayor de 5
centímetros sin diseminación a los
ganglios linfáticos la etapa 3a
significa que la mama puede tener un
tumor de cualquier tamaño y cáncer en
los ganglios linfáticos de la axila o
bien puede ser un tumor mayor de 5
centímetros y cáncer en los ganglios
linfáticos de la axila
la etapa 3 be significa que el tumor
puede ser de cualquier tamaño y que el
cáncer puede haberse diseminado a la
pared del pecho la piel de la mama
y los ganglios linfáticos de la axila
la etapa 3 se significa que la mamá
puede no tener un tumor visible o un
tumor de cualquier tamaño con
diseminación a los ganglios linfáticos
de la axila el esternón o alrededor de
la clavícula la etapa 4 significa que el
cáncer se ha diseminado a órganos
distantes
usted puede preguntarse cómo ha llegado
a tener cáncer de mama si bien es
imposible predecir exactamente quién va
a tener cáncer de mama hay algunas cosas
que pueden aumentar el riesgo
ser mujer
edad avanzada
y terapia de reemplazo hormonal
y tener el primer hijo después de los 30
años
exposición a la radiación en el pecho y
un antecedente familiar de cáncer de
mama
esta lista no incluye todos los casos
si se enfrenta un diagnóstico de cáncer
de mama continúe conversando con su
médico y su equipo de atención del
cáncer